usually you think I'm a fussy eater well
it's a power play you want to get me to
eat you'll have to wait and buy my book
here comes the plane it goes your mind
a guide to mealtime negotiation to order
call one four oh eight five five five Oh
100 that's one four oh eight five five
five zero one zero zero right now baby
operators are standing by
Green work the bar KB the temple Kings
were making plans for their newest
addition but this baby has other plans
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy
Oh No that's exactly the problem have
you learned anything
hey me no what have you learned about
puppies you guys are free no Jimbo
puppies are evil Stacey be better though
I can't read what's it say look
oh it's like they're having a little
meeting last dessert so humiliating
you're going to write babies in this job
I know how important this mission isn't
the company poop duty I got a deal with
the k ID are you I'm on a mission
there's not enough love to go around my
job is to find out why they'll give me a
double espresso and see if it someplace
around here would be some sushi I'd kill
for a spicy tuna roll right about now
boy
oh you're going to look the kids are
finally getting along that's nice
the finals succeed with this mission I
will live here forever with you okay I
will help you but just to get rid of you
deal you come to me you know you're
watching you too okay shoot you on that
how we can ask the guard I've never been
so humiliated in my life from the
fragrance better bring nothing I don't
we're not Oh anything are they've done
to me what's on the racket
did he adorable oh I've got one for you
too what bummer
rework the boss baby what that cookie
down cookies offer closer
you